[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol and
what you just heard was a new pocket
piece of mind which i'm calling a
nocturn
now when you first think of a nocturn
composers such as frederick chopin and
john field probably come to mind
chopin in particular established the
style of the romantic nocturne as we are
perhaps most familiar with it today
many of his nocturns have a calm and
arpeggiated left hand figure with a
melodic line on top
there's no formal structure to these
character pieces but many of them follow
a ternary form
they are a bit like lullabies that have
been elaborated upon and of course the
main defining characteristic is that a
nocturn is evocative of the night
here are some of my most favorite
nocturns
[Music]
in coming up with my piece i thought of
things that i associate most with the
night
i mostly think of lights and how the
mood of each street corner shifts into
something more mysterious and intense
for me the night is also when i love to
just be in my own space it's when i do
most of my brainstorming work on
projects such as editing these videos or
photos
and decompress with my dog
[Music]
all right
second attempt
this time i have the right cable
so unfortunately i just realized
by the way
thank you mom for this
really nice tote bag
which i use to carry my keyboard
okay
please stand clear
now a question for you all what do you
associate most with the knight and what
is your favorite nocturne
as always thank you so much for watching
and keeping in touch if you'd like to
find more material related to these
videos and my original music please
visit my site
you can also find a link in the
description for my new piano intensive
video course which is an in-depth study
guide into technique harmony and
practice methods while using my modified
chopin exercises thanks again and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you